foreign
the article I have here is called
depression rooms and doom piles why
clearing the Clutter can feel impossible
it's from The New York Times we'll put a
link to this in the show notes so you
can read the whole thing if you like
over at the minimalists.com podcast the
article itself is By Dana G Smith
and it's about the link between
messiness and mental health is real
these low lift tips for keeping a clean
enough home will help
a camera pans around Abigail minnows
bedroom the floor is mostly invisible
hidden by piles of clothes for a large
plastic baskets are stacked on top of
each other some filled with laundry
others with electronics there are eight
abandoned cups of coffee on the desk
beside the table
on the floor live two half empty water
bottles a novelty bottle of tequila with
a Glass Cactus inside
and a pet food dispenser
today we're going to be cleaning my
depression room the 24 year old YouTube
star who posts videos as Abby Lucia
tells the camera
I fear that the only way I will be able
to make myself clean this room
is if I film it
the term depression room is relatively
new popularized by videos on Tick Tock
and YouTube that have accrued hundreds
of millions of views but experts have
long recognized the link between
messiness and mental health the Clutter
that can accumulate when people are
experiencing a mental health crisis is
neither a form of hoarding nor the
result of laziness the culprit is
extreme fatigue said Brad Schmidt a
distinguished research professor of
psychology at Florida State University
people are oftentimes just so mentally
and physically exhausted that they don't
feel like they have the energy to take
care of themselves or their surroundings
Dr Schmidt said they just don't have the
capacity to engage with house cleaning
and upkeep that Pro they probably once
did
the article goes on to say a messy home
can also contribute to feelings of
overwhelm stress and shame making you
feel worse than you already do and while
decluttering will not cure your
depression
it can give you a mood boost if you are
struggling and it feels impossible to
keep your surroundings tidy here are a
few tips on how to clean strategically
to optimize your energy and your space
the first tip is focus on function not
Aesthetics for Casey Davis one of her
most popular strategies is quote five
things tidying the idea that there are
only five things in any room trash
dishes laundry things with a place and
things without a place those are the
five things focusing on one category at
a time keeps her from getting
overwhelmed when it seems like there are
a hundred different items that need to
be put away we would call that chunking
moving it down to these chunks so a
phone number's 10 digits but we chunk it
into three different groups right and it
makes it easier to manage than managing
all 10 numbers at once the second tip
they have in the article here is make
your home work better for you
the first step Mrs Brooks said is to
really pay attention to the items you're
frequently cleaning up then find better
places for them to live when I talk to
my clients about there's a lot about
systems she says
figuring out why things are the way they
are and where they are why clutter is
building up where it is and then
changing the design or organization
around how people are actually using
their home and so yes if I keep my all
of my bed sheets in my living room
there's going to be clutter I keep my
bed sheets on the bed if I keep my
spatula in my kitchen or from a move if
I remove it from the kitchen if I keep
my spatula in the bathroom
it's going to provide clutter if I keep
all of my
bathroom bathroom
accoutrements in the kitchen those
things are merely going to get in the
way but if everything has an appropriate
home appropriate for you
wonderful I keep my toothbrush in the
kitchen and that's okay
but it doesn't mean that you should as
well I use it most in the kitchen when I
get up in the morning I don't want to
wake up my wife or my daughter and so I
head to the kitchen where I brush my
teeth instead of
the bedroom what's right next to our or
the bathroom is right next to our bed
right yeah finally stop the problem
before it starts once your space is
cleanish and relatively decluttered try
to make a few minutes take a few minutes
each day to keep it that way Mrs Davis
recommended setting a timer for five or
ten minutes and getting as much taken
care of as you can during this time
quote I tell myself I don't have to
finish this task but I'm going to get up
for eight minutes and do it she said I'm
usually surprised at how much I can get
done I call this a setting the stage
rule Bex and I take five to ten minutes
every night and set the stage for the
next morning set our next day up for
Success put away the dishes the blankets
the random things that might be strewn
throughout the house whether it's toys
or clothes or a laundry that need to be
put away and just taking five to ten
minutes no more than 10 minutes putting
it away so I can start off the next day
with a little bit more calm dude the the
timer is brilliant because what happens
when we have too much clutter or the
house is too dirty whatever it is
um I know for me when I think about
tackling that
it's it gets overwhelming because I
don't know how long it's going to take
me and you know we always make things
harder in our minds than what they
actually are but if you can set that 20
minute timer all right I'm gonna spend
20 minutes like
getting rid of some of this stuff in the
bathroom and cleaning it and I don't
have to finish it but I got to give it
you know my all for 20 minutes and my
guess is is that you could probably
clean a bathroom in less than 20 minutes
this really helps Ella with her homework
as well the work that she has to do with
arithmetic in particular every day she
does 18 pages of math problems
and if left to her own devices she will
sit at a table for over an hour and
struggle through them if I give her
however a one minute timer and chunk it
into one minute chunks for her
she can do three pages in one minute oh
wow it takes her six minutes to do her
homework which would take more than 10
times that if he doesn't have the timer
there to watch over her and so we can do
that in our own lives as well I'm just
going to take five minutes and do this
one task you'll be surprised what you
can do you can clean the bathroom as you
said you can dust mop the floors I give
myself three minutes to dust them off
the floors and it's just three minutes
yeah and I'm so much more contented by
that because I've removed the excess
clutter that gets in the way the dust
bunnies the dirt Etc in just three
minutes it feels overwhelming before we
do it but after doing it we're so glad
that we actually took those two or three
minutes to get that jump out of the way
did you enjoy this Standalone patreon
highlight if so you can listen to full
episodes of the minimalist private
podcast available exclusively on patreon
visit patreon john.com the minimalists
or click the link in the description
your support keeps our podcast and
YouTube Channel 100
advertisement free